[Music]
this episode is brought to you by euro
ier oh I love euro and I don't know
about you guys but since kovat hit Wi-Fi
has also taken a hit because everyone's
home and spending much more time home at
least and my girlfriend and I were using
the Wi-Fi constantly we noticed dead
spots throughout the house things would
drop off calls recordings you name it it
was a huge pain in the ass and
ultimately I grabbed euro which was
originally recommended to me by Kevin
rose and it is the Wi-Fi your home
deserves it blankets it with fast
reliable Wi-Fi not just inside but
outside too so you're creating a mesh
network and it can extend your coverage
so you can enjoy the nice weather out on
your deck get work done wherever so this
has been a absolute game changer for me
it's super super easy to set up it sets
up in minutes I despite having been
involved with tech for so long I'm not
really fantastic it's setting things up
and this was dead simple you just plug
it right into your modem or a modem
router box and you manage it from a
super simple app with some very cool
features like pausing the Wi-Fi for
dinner receiving alerts if any device
attempts to join your network it's
really really easy gyro eliminates poor
coverage dead spots and buffering you'll
have a consistently strong signal
wherever you need it so for instance my
girlfriend's upstairs I'm downstairs and
we had very erratic coverage prior to
using it now it's very very consistent
apple homekit users euros got you
covered with enhanced privacy and safety
controls that give connected devices
only the permissions they need to do
what you want in your home and on the
Internet so euro has fixed my issues
with Wi-Fi at home you can get your
Wi-Fi issues fixed as soon as tomorrow
go to ero comm slashed him and enter
code Tim
at checkout to get free next day
shipping with your order that's EE ro
com slashed him code Tim at checkout to
get your era delivered with free next
day shipping you must use this URL to
receive this offer one more time check
it out
eurocom slash tim code Tim this episode
is brought to you by LinkedIn marketing
solutions right now the world is
changing a lot is changing and
businesses are adapting in different
ways so in these uncertain times how do
you ensure your marketing goals are met
how do you ensure your marketing gets
the results that you need and want with
more than 62 million decision-makers on
LinkedIn you're able to connect with the
right business leaders as well as people
who are looking to find products
services and education to help their
companies it's no surprise that 78% of
b2b marketers rate LinkedIn as the most
effective social media platform and
helping their organization achieve
specific objectives LinkedIn marketing
can help you build campaigns using
objective based advertising allowing you
to customize the campaign experience
based on the action you want your
customer to take in other words that's
true whether you're trying to drive
clicks to a website generate leads or
even generate video views my team that
is the Tim Ferriss show team is using
the platform right now on LinkedIn to
invite people to sign up for my five
bullet Friday newsletter LinkedIn has
the targeting tools that can help you
focus on reaching your precise audience
down to their job title company name
location and more in fact you can reach
people you already know based on who has
visited your site or who you've
contacted in the past LinkedIn ads can
help all types of businesses get the
marketing results that they need today
see how LinkedIn can help you with a
free $100 LinkedIn ad credit to launch
your first campaign just visit
linkedin.com slash TFS that's
linkedin.com slash TFS terms and
conditions apply
hello boys and girls ladies and
squirrels this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where is my job every
episode to interview and deconstruct
world-class performers in other words to
tease out the habits routines favorite
books and so on that you can apply to
your own lives this episode has a lot
there are a lot of strategies a lot of
tactics a lot of incredible stories and
my guest is John Paul DeJoria de jo are
I a John Paul DeJoria is an American
entrepreneur and philanthropist who has
launched multiple global enterprises and
is renowned as one of the 100 greatest
living business minds by Forbes John
Paul DeJoria is rags to riches bio is
truly incredible it exemplifies the
American Dream in a lot of ways well
it's homeless he's struggled against the
odds to craft a unique life and many
unique businesses that you know in 1980
john paul and hairstylist paul mitchell
converted a partially borrowed $700 into
John Paul Mitchell Systems which is
today the largest privately held salon
hair care line in 1989 doing something
totally different he co-founded patron
the first ultra premium tequila and now
the world's number one ultra premium
tequila which he sold to Bacardi in 2018
John Paul went on to co-found John Paul
pet rocket and many other enterprises
he's done a lot and he continues to do a
lot he's also signed The Giving Pledge
along with others like Bill Gates and
Warren Buffett as a formal promise to
continue giving back and he has
established JP's peace love and
happiness foundation as a hub for his
charitable investments which span the
core values of his company's
sustainability social responsibility and
animal friendliness this episode was
recorded in March of 2020 and due to
some technical issues who ran until we
moved part way through from Skype to
phone so you will notice that transition
there is a lot of actionable advice in
this conversation and John Paul does not
disappoint so without further ado please
enjoy this wide-ranging conversation
with none other than John Paul DeJoria
jump-off welcome to the show
why didn't you tell nice to be here on
your show you've got a great show and
you're helping a lot of people out along
the way by giving them good positive
direction thank you sir
I have looked forward to this and been
looking forward to this for at least a
year probably two years now and we have
a mutual friend
Robert Rodriguez who's certainly a
fixture here in Austin
long time resident and I thought we
would start this might seem like a
strange place to start but start with a
text exchange that I was having with him
not long ago where I was asking him
about topics or questions that we might
explore off-the-beaten-path and one
thing that stood out and that he
highlighted was that he saw a picture of
you shown by your wife from last
December at a Christmas party where you
and Smokey Robinson were showing feats
of physicality and Robert said that his
mind was blown because it looked like
you were doing full planches and moves
that you might only see at the top
levels of gymnastics could you speak to
fitness in your life you bet you
in fact smokey by the way I'm 75 B 76
here in a few more months or a few more
weeks
Smokey's up about 80 and he's
unbelievably fit now what people have to
know is this and I'm gonna quote an old
blues friend of mine no blue singer uh
he died about a decade ago I was at his
funeral that's John Lee Hooker I knew
John Lee for maybe 40 years before he
passed on and John Lee would call me for
the last seven years on my birthday
every year as well as my wife he calls
on her birthday and he make up some
blues riff and sing it to us and for
those last seven years my daughter
Alexis a racecar driver and I went to
his house when he was in this long beach
house or a San Jose House hang out with
him on his birthday so he called he said
JP I want you to record this it's okay
he never asked me to record anything so
we went out bought when he's $29
recorders you plug into your telephone
so you could record the conversation on
a cassette tape and we did
so he made up a blues riff to really
cool blues riffs he kind of made it up
as he went along the way singing and
then he stopped in the middle of it now
what I'm gonna tell you is quite amazing
because John Lee Hooker was illiterate
until the day he died could even write
out his own name
just as initials alliterative the day he
died in the middle of this blues rift he
stopped and said remember you will
always be as old as your mind leads you
to believe and then went right back to
the blues rift again smokey my dear
buddy Smokey Robinson knew that he wants
to be on stage and he's one of the best
performers and best singers in the world
the world's ever known
smokey knows he's got to be fit so
smokey learned along the time in his
life no matter what age he is that if he
were to do not only sit-ups but raise
his feet up in the air
lay flat raise your feet up in the air
which really tightens up your entire
core if he keeps on doing that by gosh
he's gonna do it for a long time he's 80
he's doing it beautifully he looks like
a gymnastics person when I was in high
school 16 and 17 years old I was in
gymnastics my thing was the pommel horse
a side horse a rope climb but I also
learned how to do things like from a
handstand going to a full lever where
your whole body is a parallel with the
ground and you're holding yourself up
with actually ten fingertips two hands
that's it so what I did was I started
doing that oh gosh I'd say maybe 20
years ago once or twice year I would do
it and then I was with a lot of super
cool people bye buddy Matthew
McConaughey had his birthday and I went
to his birthday and these guys were so
fit it's incredible Matthew being a nice
guy I was in a tank top we're in the
middle of the desert and with his 50 of
his best pals and he kind of rubbed me
down with oil on my shoulders say JP
here let's put some oil on you and all
those guys were lifted and weights they
were all buff these little guys look
like mr. America but you know Matthew
McConaughey is a very well preserved
very buff person himself anyways they
said JP you know lift 20 30 pound lifts
whatever you can I said I bet I can do
some of you guys can do he goes wait a
minute he stopped he brought everybody
over right and I did exactly what you
saw in that picture and words I was
able to race myself up with my to faint
with my two hands totally parallel with
the ground nobody else could do it
so what smokey and I got together over
to the South around the holidays were
missing each other his wife my wife had
some dear friends we both did that let's
get our feet up in the air together and
we did that and right afterwards I went
into that full plank expanded in the air
but the whole thing is this don't limit
yourself in life by your age or what you
think you're capable of doing
you're always as old as your mind leads
you to believe and there's a lot of
things you could do if you truly
believed you could do it and if you
can't do it now do little portions of it
until you can do it
that's incredible hee hee meaning Robert
described you as looking like spider-man
what does your weekly exercise routine
look like if if you have a somewhat
consistent routine it's not really
consistent
I'd say though probably three times a
week I will do what they call Navy SEAL
push-ups these things you hold on to and
twist and I'll do maybe 25 of them 2-3
times a week
that's about the extent of it maybe once
or twice a month I'll pick up 25 pounds
in each hands and you know do a couple
of curls or something that takes me a
minute and a half and that's the extent
of it hmm I walk a lot and I walk fast
you walk a lot you walk fast yep I think
walking is definitely underrated and
what does your diet look like my diet is
probably 90% to 95% vegetarian I still
you know like my fish my shrimp my
organic free-range no antibiotic chicken
but I'm pulling away from that in fact I
used to eat a little bit of meat but I'm
pulling away from that also so I think
and eventually it'll be more vegetarian
with just a little bit of fish in there
but much more vegetarian I think that's
where it's going to end up and a lot of
people think that I think because of
whatever old school medical people ever
said is you got to have meat your body
to be strong but then again I say well
wait a minute an elephant is the
strongest animal on the planet it eats
no meat wells eat krill they don't even
eat fish
and they're pretty strong too and I
believe to the best of my knowledge that
apes monkeys gorillas who are very very
strong are vegetarians so that I'm kind
of changing my eating habits I don't
think man was made to eat meat and I did
believe that - more recently some kind
of changing in that direction I've had a
guest in the podcast of previous world
champion in Olympic or say world record
holder in Olympic weightlifting named
Jersey Gregor ik originally from Poland
who also primarily for prostate reasons
active lower inflammatory markers has
moved more to a vegetarian diet and he
is one of the fittest humans I know so
certainly there are ways I think to
deviate from a meat heavy diet without a
doubt I'd love to jump back in time can
I do that can I back a dykes is sub good
to share with everybody yes please
oatmeal is one the I eat oatmeal err
almost every morning and what I've done
here is because apples are very good for
you if you take a whole Apple and you'll
of course cut out the core and chop it
in little pieces
cook it with your oatmeal cook it with
the oatmeal put a little bit honey on it
number one you've got one of the most
greatest foods ever an apple in you to
start your day and oatmeal is one of the
best things ever for your system in
clearing you out another thing - and you
could get it over the Internet it's
called daily restore like re sto our you
know restore restore some daily restore
it's a probiotic that's made up of I
believe it's nine probiotics and oh god
I want to say maybe just as many enzymes
but they're doing research with it right
now where it's found to do things that
are so unbelievable to the immune system
it's even hard to believe but if you go
online to have their medical research on
there you can look at it but I've been
taking those also these super probiotics
that they make that daily restore makes
that are just phenomenal I mean these I
haven't had a col I don't think in uh in
2530 years I've even had a cold is there
anything else that you consume on a
daily basis or do on a daily basis sighs
a coma very good most days not all but
most
I have a nice glass or two of a good red
wine do you have a favorite one or is it
I have there's quite a few I I have
quite a few you know there's there some
really good ones out there from Italy
from France and from the United States
there's some really good ones out there
uh they're really good ones out there so
I'll let everybody take their choice for
me I would say from from a United States
of America wine I like a famous Private
Reserve
Camus is a good red wine but they're
Private Reserve Cabernet is really
incredible that's a really good one
and there's other certain this other
really good wines out there uh you know
they shot told lafite-rothschild zhaibar
goes are very good too but you know even
though you go to South Africa they've
got good whites out of Australia good
whites are coming and I even had a great
wine out of Chile and a great wine out
of Spain so there's some really good red
wines out there try and get him without
any sulfates in of there better let's
strike a contrast with the Camus Private
Reserve and jump to a quote that I read
in research for this conversation which
may or may not be accurate but it's will
jump from Camus Private Reserve to 27
cents so the quote I have in front of me
is attributed to your mother saying to
your brother and yourself quote you know
between us we only have 27 cents but we
have a refrigerator we have our little
garden out back and we're happy so we're
rich can you put that in context yeah I
sure can we grew up with very very
little as my mother we had a deadbeat
dad I never saw him after two years old
until I was a teenager still a deadbeat
dad anyways so was really my mom
struggling to raise two boys so my mom
really struggled a lot to raise his kids
she worked in downtown LA designing hats
but from the time I was 11 years old my
brother was 13 we had paper routes with
the LA Examiner in the morning we give
our mom
just about all the money we made all the
paper route so we could have a little
better way of life because it was a bit
of a struggle so one day we were home
and my mom said there's a lot of love in
my house mom was just the most loving
mom and she did everything she took the
place of her mom and dad both she was
just great anyway she said boys let's
see how much money we have he
we have food in the refrigerator we have
food on the shelves and we have our
little garden around back and it's the
weekend let's see what we have so we all
put our money together we came up with
27 cents between the three of us my
mother my brother and I and mom said she
said we're the richest people nor look
at this we have everything we're happy
we have love and we still have some
money isn't that wonderful
and we other percent agreed with her and
that's where you go into what is the
true meaning of success in life and rich
success is not how much money you have
or how powerful you are success is how
well do you do what you do when nobody
else is looking when I was in high
school I worked for Stuart's cleaners
one of my jobs after school and one day
Stuart came up to me and he said Johnny
you my gosh are the best most successful
janitor in the world I was upstairs
the other night looking around I dropped
something on the floor looked under the
bunk in my mezzanine and there was no
dust I moved it there was no dust the
cabinets removed there was no dust
behind him you did what nobody else does
you weren't as if I was watching you
every single minute I'm gonna give you a
25 cent race now when you're making a
dollar in a quarter an hour did you get
a 25 cent raise that is a big deal when
you're wrong you know in high school I
was at least for making money when I was
in high school in the late fifties early
sixties that was a big deal so I do Wow
I was a most successful person so
success is how well do you do what
you're doing and continue to do it at
your best
when nobody else is looking and how far
have you come if somebody came from
being homeless to having a job they're
successful if somebody went from being a
janitor to all of us I'm getting raises
or a supervisory job boy are they
successful how well do you do what you
do when no one else is looking what is
rich rich isn't money you could have all
the money in the world and there's two
people like this that are unhappy and
unhealthy riches what's click of the
priorities number one is happiness
number two is health if you don't have
happiness you're not gonna have the best
of health if you have happiness and
health you have to the richest things on
the planet everything else comes after
that but
it has to be you have to have a giving
heart and be able to give to others and
know that you're here not just take care
of yourself on the planet but do
something to make life better for other
people you have all those things going
boy you're just rich and so landed hard
and thinking and then whatever comes
long after that's gonna come along even
more beautifully hmm you mentioned you
mentioned homeless I think that we might
as well segue there sure many questions
for you and we'll probably bounce around
but you mentioned being homeless is it
true that you've been homeless I'm not
not one occasion right two occasions
right that is good you can you describe
how those those two periods and
homelessness happened
sure it sucked what had happened first
time I was 22 years old and I was
working as a master of ceremonies at the
second annual sports vacation
recreational vehicle show I was young 22
years old when I got the job anyways I
came home from that job and when I came
home from it it was down in Anaheim I
was living in the at water area at that
time of Los Angeles and I was a young
wife very young wife we were like a year
apart we shouldn't even had kids we had
a two-year-old child so I came home and
as I came home and pulled the only car
into the driveway she came down the
stairs and said oh I've got to run over
to the store so she took the keys and
jumped in the car and took off well by
the time I got upstairs she was long
gone right there smack in the middle of
our little living room was our
two-year-old son with my clothes piled
their little pile of clothes and a note
basically saying that I can't handle
being a mom anymore he'll do better off
with you could bye and good luck
unbeknownst to me what little we had in
the bank she totally took out this is
all manipulated by her she totally took
out everything out of the bank the day
before everything but little we had
wasn't a lot little she had not paid the
rent or the utility bills for three
months meaning that she pocketed all
that money I was not going to get paid
for another week to ten days from there
the show that I did you know they give
you a Wii you put in your request a week
before you get paid I had almost nothing
on me and then the next day surprise
they
to evict us they had already put up
notices which she ripped up for the
eviction so there we are
you know debt down and out flat out and
no card no nothing so I got ahold of
this 1951 caddy with a broken water-pump
yet put water in it every four hours and
we were on the street and the way we got
around was you know when you're down and
out you can only think about okay the
next thing is survival got a place to
live
we got pillows couches towels you get
all this stuff we just piled in the car
there and some clothes got to eat so I
went around to vacant lots and picked up
soda pop bottles in those days grocery
stores and liquor stores took them from
you you got two cents for a little one
five cents for a big one and we just
went around collecting him off vacant
lots coke machines wherever we could
find them seven out machines cashing
them in and that's how we got by short
time later ran across the spend of mine
it was what you would call a really
hardcore biker and this name was Lee
Meyer
he said JP I got an extra in my house
once you come on over you and your son
could be there and some of our biker
mamas oh I'll take care of him while
you're out there working so by that time
he had landed another job but of course
I wasn't paid either for another job for
another two weeks until I finally got a
paycheck out of that and and that's how
we kind of got out of it second time was
when I started Paul Mitchell we needed a
half a million dollars there was no way
I could start a hair care company for
under half a million dollars so we got a
half a million dollars a fellow named
dick holthouse we're through Citicorp
arranged it for a european investor to
invested so everything i was doing at
the time I left a I'm starting my own
business with my pal Paul Mitchell we're
gonna start our own business he's a
hairdresser I'm a businessman and a
formulator this is gonna be great
I don't do hair he doesn't do business
what a perfect combination and we've
been buddies for the last nine years
right
and the money's coming so I left
everything I did my relationship wasn't
going well at all at that time so I left
the newer car even though it was a good
used car in the newer car with my wife
at the time where my child and a
daughter that time and I took the older
car down the hill and to get the money
because coming in at Bank of America it
never showed up
long story short the guy
why'd he pull out its 1980 in 1980 our
hostages were still held in I Ron 1980
and 81 we were through some bad times we
stayed in line to get gasoline inflation
in the United States was 12%
well unemployment in the United States
was 10 and a half percent if you could
get a loan I say if you could get a loan
prime rate on a loan was 17 percent if
you could even get a loan terrible times
but between Paul and I we came up with
350 bucks each I had a couple hundred
bucks in my pocket live in my car once
again
and that's how we started John Paul
Mitchell Systems we believe what we have
was so good and all the people we had
already set up gave us 30 day billing so
it was a matter of okay we better do
this we better do that in fact if you're
lifting audience has a chance
pick up the documentary good fortune
like a good fortune good fortune
documentary I did about three and a half
four years ago it talks about the whole
story how to survive two homelessness
and how to create not one but two
businesses after that this turned out to
be billion-dollar businesses each so
you've done so many things in your life
and we won't go through the entire list
but you mentioned janitor yep and I want
you I want you to fact check me if I get
anything wrong sure I also door-to-door
in encyclopedia sale over three years
sold encyclopedias started or Colliers
it's commission only right so you have
you have this long period of many
different hats that you've worn how did
you get to formulating and the the John
Paul Mitchell Systems get along the way
I was 26 years old and one of my jobs is
working for Time Inc in their
circulation department of sports fortune
Sports Illustrated and Life magazine it
was basically a boiler room where people
would call to get people to renew their
subscriptions or get new subscriptions
well I went to my vice pres and I said
look you know I want what do I have to
become a vice president I don't want to
do this rest of my life you know I'd
like to know how to go ahead he said you
have no college you only a high school
graduate and you're only 26 years old
come back in a school year 35 well I
certainly want to wait at a job I did
not like and offered in writing more
years so a friend of mine John Capra was
an employment counselor where people had
pay him to get people to go to work from
them so he sent me on several jobs and I
ended up after trying a few of them out
to working for a company in the
professional beauty industry has a
salesman period to sell beauty supplies
well why was that with that company I
went all the way up to national manager
of to their divisions with the company
but I got involved in learning how they
formulated some of these products who
did it how they did it what they did and
then I worked after that they fired me
by the way because I complained that
they were testing on animals it was the
wrong thing to do well that dinkler go
with management so they fired me
Angela's wrong wrong wrong they said
well you care more about animals and
people than you do about the corporation
you're not a corporate guy so they fired
me all right that was retconned by the
way recognized that company but I said
but we you're firing me but why are you
testing on animals it's stupid they said
because it makes us look good we're the
scientific approach
anyway so just as well I was gone the
next company went to work for was the
company purchased by Centex
a pharmaceutical company a company
called for banal and firma dollars doing
about 8 million a year in business there
in the United States and they hired me
to train their management their sales
management their sales staff and
educators when one year we increase the
business by 50 percent but I learned
while I was there more about formulating
and where to go to get different things
and they ended up firing me because once
again I wasn't part of Management
I cared more about people and getting
him off the road and not leaving him out
there for many many weeks than I did
about the company's expenses and what
was cheaper for the company so and also
they had they had some things I didn't
agree with that weren't very very nice
anyways I went for it worked for a third
company and I did very well I tripled
their shelves or very little but I
tripled ourselves that first year I was
with them and they came before day and
said we could get somebody to do your
job for only what half of what you're
making or less they said so there I said
well wait a minute guys I just tripled
your sales you're little but your sales
tripled how about this you pay me the
three thousand dollars a month which my
salary was but the six percent that
you're giving me for sales increases you
cut that in half and let me buy what the
other half 10 percent of your company
said no way absolutely not
I said but guys you know most the money
I made was off increased sales
they said I know but the increased sales
was so much that you mean more than the
owner of the company I solved every way
so I left but at that company at that
company I learned more about formulating
were to buy bottles were to get
silkscreen and all this so I was set up
beautifully to be able to start my own
company after that and then I did I
started a consulting company but I told
you everything you needed to know in
three months you didn't need me anymore
so I'd have to go through a lot of
clients so that's what I decided let's
start my own thing
let's look let's look at one of the
themes the three lines here is being
very good at increasing sales you became
the national manager of two divisions
time get remembering correctly we just
said a read can tripled sales at this
company you just mentioned how did you
become so good at sales and what made
you good at increasing sales when I was
selling newspaper
door-to-door and delivering in the
morning we would deliver the morning and
the way we sold the door-to-door was we
would go by after school and knock
door-to-door and trying to convince them
to take the la examiner for the morning
delivery in our area everyone we got we
got one dollar for so I learned how to
knock on a lot of doors and take a lot
of rejection but the big one was when I
was in my 20s and I sold encyclopedias
door-to-door I got out of the Navy and I
went to work for PL Collier incorporated
Colliers encyclopedia and I learned how
to sell encyclopedias door-to-door now
in my training class they said this to
you look and by the way it was
commissioned only you and even during
training you mean no money it was
commissioned only with every so and
there were no leads you were
door-to-door knocking but they sense up
to me that I believed they said the
people that make it will make good money
are the people that don't give up a lot
of doors can be slammed in your face but
you must be just as enthusiastic on door
number 101 if 100 were closed in front
of you and I believe them and they were
right it took me over a week to get my
first order but I did and I lasted uh
three and a half years while I was doing
that which was more than the average
three days an encyclopedia salesmen
lasted in those days so I learned how to
overcome rejection which was very
healthy and then when I got along the
way and I started saying other products
I could only sell what I believed in so
I saw the people is this if you're gonna
sell something don't really be in the
selling business you don't want to be in
the selling businesses one of the big
secrets I give everybody whether it's a
service you're selling or a product
you're selling whether you work for
yourself or somebody else don't be in
the selling business be in the reorder
business in other words your service is
so good or your product is so good that
whoever you sold it to is want to order
it and reorder it again or tell somebody
if it's a one-time product how great
that product or that service was that's
why things work you don't lie to people
you don't con people you tell them the
truth about it but in such a way word
you go back and see him a month a year
later and what she sold them service or
product was so good they're already
reordering and that's how I don't and
how I treat people and how I train them
be kind to people be nice to them but at
the same time look them in the eye and
make sure that what you have is so darn
good that you would convince your mother
if you love your mother to get it and
here's why there's excellence and then
we flash forward to I guess forward and
backwards to a few hundred dollars along
with Paul Mitchell and you guys are
gonna take on the world
yep what is what is that what is the
pitch and who are you pitching well we
had it set up where all of our vendors
the bottle maker the soap screener the
filler and the warehouse had filled it
for us oh and some of the ingredients
were all set up for 30 days they knew
what we're doing was gonna be big they
knew he had this money coming in so what
happened was this how do you do it when
you have no money now well it was a
hundred thousand bottles was our first
run so I called up the bottle maker and
I say can I just have a sample run I
didn't tell you were broke I just like
we have a sample run of only 10,000
bottles a so of course we understand a
sample run I told a silk strainer we
have a sample run coming only 10,000
bottles and I told the fillers same
exact thing so we would have 4,000
bottles of a conditioner 3000 of shampoo
one 3000 shampoo - and it took him for
the time we said go it took them two
weeks to make it and by the way we had
700 dollars in our hand both key thing
was we need it the artwork for the silk
screener we went to been told the truth
hey your bills a thousand dollars for
this artwork isn't black and white thank
God we stopped putting any color onyx
and couldn't afford that we only have
$700 can we give you $300 now and give
you the rest later
he said no he said because I'll never
get the rest later give me $700 it's a
three hundred dollar discount I'll give
you your artwork well we did so all I
had was a few hundred bucks in my pocket
I bought some money from my mom a few
hundred bucks in my pocket Paul had the
same to use on his last money and that's
how we started I piled stuff in my car
and drove up in Los Angeles and sure
Boulevard go in salon de salón a salon
now why do we pick salons we had no
advertising money no promotional money
but three companies I worked for the REC
Ken and the firm Adele and the try all
three of those were selling to be salon
so we knew the industry and when you
also that if you have something really
good win a darn good product like really
good and we usually have something that
good and we gave it to a salon first
alone was using it they would buy it
from us and use it they would see how
good it was for their hands and the
person's hair that they would want to
reorder and recommend it to people to
take home in between visits and they did
so that's that's the market we went
after and we stayed with that market in
fact even today even today if you ever
see a Paul Mitchell product in any
drugstore or supermarket it is either
out the back door through the black gray
market or it's counterfeit or mixed
together we only sell to salons and the
demand sometimes is so big that some
stores will go to salon pay full price
for it
take it up at one or two dollars as a
lot as a leader and have it on their
shelves it's amazing you know it is just
amazing many times counterfeit gets
mixed with the gray market product and
that's sold to people also and of course
they figure well how can some of these
big stores these my god is big chain
groups have counterfeit or black market
product but they do because they know
they could get away with it legally
it's wild I know you mentioned something
earlier that I want to come back to you
and that is working with your suppliers
and manufacturers and you said they knew
it was going to be big so they were
working with you on net 30 terms at
30-day payment - sure how did they how
did you convince them that it was going
to be big so they should bet on you and
give you those guns you have very darn
good question I presented to them here
national manager reckons chain salon
division school division from it all
response for all training and education
for their management team and selling
team is to defy ecology vice-president
of sales and marketing Paul Mitchell
were the most avant-garde hairdressers
of the day so here's our credentials so
it was based on that and I took them all
I showed the letters about the 500,000
coming in that were sent to me showed
them all that you know
so they said wow this is quite so guys
li you work with me on this one I'd like
30-day billing and here's what I would
like and that's that's how it happened
and of course I was I was very
presentable at the time and looked right
in the eyeball and I was very sincere
very honest and they realized that
nobody thought someone would pull out
the very end so it's really funny
because I know getting our first
distributor in Los Angeles I went to
Paris face Beauty Supply Jim Henriette
was a general manager and president of
that whole operation big P supply store
huge salesman going everywhere and I
went down there to show my products and
I said you know God if you uh if you'll
take our product line on we will you
know give you an exclusive on all of LA
and Orange County big area right and he
laughed and he said to me well why
should I take your products on we're
Paris a speedy supply we have all the
big lines why do we want to spend time
to build your line when you guys have an
unknown line it doesn't make any sense
well what I did two weeks prior was I
went up Ventura Boulevard knocking
door-to-door on salons after a week I
got 12 orders I delivered him on the
spot and got 12 checks but they left
top line blank so when he sent that to
me I said here's why you should get us
in front of him I put out 12 orders and
12 checks I should see that top line
parasites be supplies going in it I've
already got your first 12 customers and
if you will let me give you this line
just by 2000 from me if you have to
because we were really hard up just by
$2,000 from us you could have all of LA
in Orange County right he laughed his
head off and said oh my god is okay but
you better be here every single day
working with all my salesmen till they
sell it all I said it's a deal I said
there's one more thing too we started
out with virtually very very little here
but can you please pay your your bill
when I when the orders arrives he
laughed and said no we're parasites do
you supply we don't pay our bill for 45
days so I said well give you a 5%
discount if you'll pay your bill when it
arrives I said I can do that much for
you he laughed and said okay this is
nothing I normally do but I'll give you
a break but you better show up well he
came to our 25th anniversary 15 years
ago and he told one of our history says
so within five minutes of the time JP
was in my office my loading dock man
called me and said hey there's some guy
here and loaded a bunch of black and
white products on her steps there and he
wants to check for $2,000 ship said he I
laughed my head off
he was just to my office and I went back
and I gave JP this yet Oh cuz that is
what some of my friends would call foot
spa well I think it was a lot of that
done is the great guy Jim Turner I'll be
just a fact gave us a break he's like a
guy named Paul Mitchell took a whole
punch with the back to a why where he
was living and would go around to sell
it to all his friends and salons you get
the
I mean what suppose a good word for it
the e occurred to be another persuasion
beö serve part of the cell did you get
that from anyone in your family growing
up is something you developed on your
own where did that how was that for us I
would say twofold number one my mother
was always very positive boys you could
do anything she's very positive
supportive second of all in the three
and a half years I've sold encyclopedias
door-to-door no leads I learned more
about selling and about people than one
could ever imagine
they're no longer they haven't been
hunting for 20 years anymore
door-to-door encyclopedia salesman I
don't think that exists anymore maybe no
more encyclopedia salesmen exist anymore
but boy if they sure did every one of my
kids would be doing that for at least
three months out of their wife to learn
what it's really like and really learn
how to talk to people and convince
atleast listen to you to give you a
chance to tell your story huh of course
since that time you refined it you learn
more and more better things so I look at
his I'm not really a Salesman though the
word salesmen describes it but I really
go out there trying to help people make
the right decision some debts could be
good for them and better than what they
have or something they could probably
need one of the one of the best
salespeople I've them that was that was
not technically a salesperson who is
actually a systems engineer in
technology this is at a storage area
networking company a long time ago Jason
history listening and talking about you
and he was also at one point a
door-to-door encyclopedia social or some
period of time and became I want to say
a regional manager and he said the same
thing that had taught him more about
selling and persuasion and negotiate and
so on that anything else he's done what
made you better
aside from just sheer persistence in the
face of rejection they were there other
insights or techniques that made you
better than the competition that's yeah
I try to tell people the truth here's
what you get even though the
presentation was kind of an unusual uni
presentation where you you're paying for
everything but you get the major sack
but PD is free when the reallity are
actually paying for everything but its
own they call it a competition offer
right but to be honorable like here's
what you get and here's what you're
paying and here's why I think it's good
for you and here's why I think you might
think it's good we would talk about a
little bit in other words you included
I've included the people in the
conversation in other words what you
want to do is find a need in the
marketplace and fill it if the need
doesn't exist and create a need that
maybe wasn't there for example in sac
repeat your sales I would have to go to
the library to look up things for a
homework encyclopedia if I had one at
home it would have been great well we
could never afford it so I thought boy
it'd be great if someone could afford
have instead of its Cyclopes in their
house would be a wonderful thing they
can look it up right there we'd have
computers in those days how did this
translate to your experience with patron
how did that come about well patron I
started in 1989 and I came about I was
sitting around with a friend of mine who
we went bankrupt in the hospitality
business Martin he went bankrupt so I
went and I was introduced to him and I
was a joint venture partner with him
where I put up the money he did the work
in an unique architectural product
company he would go to Mexico by pavers
and furniture come back to United States
and sell it to architects for their
model homes or to restaurants you buy it
real cheap there very nice made
furniture by the way and bring it up
here well that did ok but after a year
wasn't it really making a lot of money
but it was existing and then was going
down there to purchase some things and I
said Martin we're at my house making
margaritas out of the tequila of the day
and I said Martin when you're down there
why don't you find out what the Mexican
aristocrats drink I bet you they drink
tequila a lot better than what we're
drinking now where you got a your breath
to drink it or you do a shot you know
mixed with a margarita
okay so Martin came back with a couple
of bottles just long thin bottles and it
was the smoothest tequila I ever had he
said but JP I met a guy down there named
fancy Scalia Dez and he said he could
make it smoother so make a long story
short he found this bottle that was
recycle glass and I said Martin here's
what I'll do it is Luther and he's
making it even smoother I will go ahead
and buy by this time I was doing pretty
good with the Paul Mitchell products
I'll go ahead and I'll buy one thousand
cases that's twelve thousand bottles and
even though it's very expensive to me if
everything went wrong I'd be able to
have a some of the best to heal in the
world and give my friends for the next
ten years for every occasion that came
up no matter what it is they're great
ballin tequila so anyways we did it when
we first started to the United States
Eric
nobody wanted to carry it it was 37
dollars a bottle and the average tequila
was around four or five dollars a bottle
the most expensive one I think was $14 a
bottle at the time nobody wanted to
carry it we convinced a wine merchant
who only sold wine to carry a product
and sell it and we would promise that if
they would do that I person would go
down to hold her sales meeting and you
know we would show how to sell it and if
they took us on I would get him one of
the top accounts in Beverly Hills and
Martin would get him one the top Mexican
restaurants and they love you guys could
do that let's give it a try so we did
Martin went to his friends at Baja
Cantina in Marina del Rey I went to my
friend Wolfgang Puck at Spago's the
hottest restaurant of the day there in
West Hollywood and he took it on so we
kept our promise but after a year they
were selling very very little and so we
dropped him we took on Jim Beam this is
a good story for your listeners we took
on Jim Beam very big company by the way
their distribution everywhere and they
had some very very good alcohol and they
sold themselves that they made but they
decided to take us on after about a year
and a half they were only selling I
believe was about 12,000 cases a year so
Martin and I sat down with them and said
guys you know we've been going around
opening up little nightclubs or
restaurants for you and you know and we
contributed something but you know you
guys really needed to twelve thousand
you should be doing you know we thought
we could do like 5060 thousand one day
of this product cases a year you know
they said guys let's tell you the truth
okay you do have the best tequila in the
world there's no doubt but your price is
too high people don't want to pay that
kind of money
I better tell you guys you will one day
reach 20,000 cases a year but that's
about it guys we drop Jim Beam and took
on Seagram's secret stick is up to 70
thousand cases a year and we thought we
could do a lot better we went to court
with them ended up buying him out of
their agreement with us which we did and
we took over the distribution ourselves
and it had started going up up up up up
up up and then mark Rowley unfortunately
died of a heart attack back in not
nearly 2000s and mr. Edie brown was our
president his vice president sales at
the time immediately he should have been
pressed I made a press in the company we
focused on really doing this property
Ned brown gets 90% of the credit for all
of this he really does it sensational
man he brought on a great team and we
built and we built and we focused on
patron being the star not a beautiful
girls you know in the ad but the patron
was the star and then we started
bringing it out to other people and
other channels and through Paul Mitchell
my hair care company we would have a big
event every year where two or three
thousand the top hairdressers throughout
the United States and the world would
come to it and we would serve them free
patron well they would go back home and
ask for because it was so good but make
a very long story short I sold my
interest in patron a year and a half ago
when I did we were approaching overall
with everything in the company we were
approaching close to four million cases
a year that's just under 50 million
bottles you know I think the patron
cells alone were oh god I don't know
maybe three million three hundred
thousand something like that but with
all the rest of things it was
approaching four million cases so the
lesson to be learned here is if anybody
tells you something when there's
limitations you don't necessarily have
to believe them what patron sold it sold
for the highest amount ever paid a
company in the alcohol business why it
was the finest product ever again going
back to the very very best that you have
your service you're probably sought to
be the best year in the reorder business
and we did a lot of good things to make
people happy and honorable we would
throw big events for charities we would
take care of orphanages we're still in
fact rebuilding houses
down at the st. Bernard project in New
Orleans least we were up until the time
he sold it to Picardie enough they're
still doing that or not so you know it
was all built up some of the principles
that I learned along the way and our
other people learned to and of course
Edie Brown really instilled a lot of
into people how was it for you in the
beginning learning to navigate and maybe
there are similar regulations and legal
limitations and so on with with the Paul
Mitchell book but with patron I would
imagine there's there's a lot to
navigate from a yes we're in legal
standpoint was that it was that
difficult what was that like for you
well no because the reason wasn't
difficult was because I use certain
things attorneys had to do and as we
started growing bigger at Brown you
everything else had to be done but
Martin and I at the very beginning knew
there were certain things to do and
Martin I financed the thing Martin was
able to go out there and get it
registered the way we were someone gets
the credit for that and had brown for
once it took off by God he'd put all the
other things in the place if someone
were to and I'm sure this has been done
that was to say Harvard Business School
there's a case study on patron what do
you think some of the best decisions
would be strategic or otherwise that
they would high event when I say Cedric
first of all if you want to see the raw
side of it ah a lady named Elana
Edelstein wrote a book called the patron
way and she shows the other side behind
the doors of patron what went on in her
life and Martin fly does Martin's
girlfriend what went on in their lives
which is very unusual to have a
successful business very unusual but it
worked you know we went into this
business not knowing anything about
alcohol but we learned along the way but
it's very interesting to read that book
of hers it's a great book to study off
of and what I would say is this you
could start a business and as long as
you believe what you have which Martin
did okay and I did is going to be the
very very best there's no limit to what
you can do but there's certain things
you've got to do and once again it would
have never been as successful as it is
if we did not have the best product on
the market that people wanted to reorder
and again we told people to truth about
patron we gave them samples of patron so
they could taste without even buying it
many times and uh you know that these
are just some of the secrets and if you
also take a look at again good fortune
to documentary it lets you know how to
build a company from from basically
scratch gives you a lot of advice there
too
so let's you don't mind look at the
pricing for a second because this year
because this is fascinating to me I've
always been a proponent of ultra-premium
when possible new positions to always be
a market for the best when every other
category might be so you have you have
bottled Gila in the landscape in the US
when you enter the market so for four to
five dollars and then you come out with
a bottle that sells for thirty seven
dollars right so let's just pretend that
we're talking cups of coffee right it's
a four to five dollar cup of coffee
right now let's say Starbucks and you
want to sell the retailer's Starbucks
you're independent on a $37 cup of
coffee that is the best in the world
what were some of the things that you
taught the retailers in your sales
meetings coming down to help them to
hello that's such a great question we
told them this what you sell it to a bar
or you sell it to a liquor store tell
them this if somebody wants to hila
you just say yes we get your favorite
one or you could treat yourself and get
a bottle of patron yes we give you your
margarita or for a dollar more you could
treat yourself we could make your
margarita with patron the best in the
world little things like that of
tremendous tremendous help tremendous
help yeah a dollar a dollar per mixed
drink involving tequila and that
certainly provides a significant revenue
stream for that given bar for instance
oh and then that dried out lately
you're right and it turned out to be
later on for three dollars more you
could have patron yeah
just a quick thanks to our sponsors and
then we're right back to the show first
up LinkedIn marketing solutions linkedin
has the targeting tools that can help
you reach your precise audience down to
their job title company name location
and more CL LinkedIn can help you with a
free $100 LinkedIn ad credit to launch
your first campaign visit linkedin.com
slash TFS as in Tim Ferriss show again
that's linkedin.com slash TFS terms and
conditions apply second and last euro EE
ro euro is the Wi-Fi your home deserves
it's a mesh network super simple to set
up that blankets your home with fast
reliable Wi-Fi go to ero dot-com / Tim
and it's a code Tim at check out to get
free next day shipping with your order
that's EE ro comm / Tim code Tim at
checkout to get your euro delivered with
free next day shipping yeah I bet the
profile this is this is an older profile
in 2013 this is an ink magazine at least
at the time that and I'll just I'll just
read this and it's may have changed but
I'd love to hear certainly 2013 email
was ubiquitous the headquarters were
Paul Mitchell in patron each have a fax
machine for one purpose communicating
with me that's referring to you I don't
use you know or a computer I would be so
inundated but I wouldn't be able to get
any work done
instead I do everything in person or by
phone I'm a phone book that's 15 years
old so why down rewrites I carry that
everywhere that may have changed but can
you speak to how you did business I
really like your questions because it's
hard for you to believe nothing has
changed today the majority of what I do
is philanthropic whether it's
representing you know Paul Mitchell or
Rock Mobile any of those companies still
in cropping the majority of what I do
these days even with patron you know
until entropic us associated with some
of these companies they get good credit
for that too but I do not have email I
do not have a computer that I turn on
all my other companies of involvement
are very computerized state-of-the-art
but all my companies have a fax machine
and I'm involved with and I have a fax
machine whatever house I'm in at the
time I fax machines and here's the
reason why if I was on the Internet
and I had email I'd be so inundated I
couldn't do all the wonderful things
that I do right now I could do it I'd be
fully inundated and I also I'm from the
old school
I like personal contact if you call me
or write me chances are I'll either take
that same letter and se you back on that
same piece of paper or I'll pick up the
phone and call you and hey how you doing
you know nice to talk to you here you
know and I'd like to communicate with
people
I think that's missing a lot in life
today we don't communicate with people
and also by not having email I'm able to
pay attention to the vital few and
ignore the trivial many I'd love to hear
you expand on that because this is
something so many people strive to do
and so many people fail to do
consistently how do you determine for
yourself what the vital few are and
happy to look at philanthropic
activities but is surely also helpful to
hear a few business examples I think
it's just for me example of like what's
important for example one of our Paul
Mitchell schools is concerned about a
challenge they have and they write me
and ask me about it well I'm liable just
to pick up the phone to call them and
say well here's your challenge here's I
think you should overcome it and we talk
about a little bit together to overcome
it or if we have our peace love and
happiness right for example I do that
with my friend Gary every year around my
birthday we have the peace love and
happiness motorcycle right
well we had a big challenge this time no
nobody's gonna get together with 150
people because of this stupid virus
that's going around right now which is
very bad so Gary and I said okay we
talked about it over the phone and he's
one of my neighbors so wasn't long
before you end up coming down to the
house here but over the phone we talked
about it Gary
let's do this let us both have the right
if it's only you and me writing this
right we'll still continue it's gone on
now for 17 years we're gonna still have
a peace love and happiness right because
whatever money we raise goes to first
responders that are injured or killed in
the line of duty like paramedics firemen
police officers things like that we're
gonna have we're gonna still do that and
a lot of it goes to to the military we
did for the Navy SEALs also and uh
shall we say military people they come
back injured we try and take care of
them too but so we'd have to get let's
make that let's do it ourselves and
that's something we personally could do
then Gary came down the next day and we
planned the whole thing out together to
still have our right
it's things of that nature you know that
you know just nice to pick up a phone
and talk to somebody if you have a if
you have a bigger countless here in
business either for yourself or
representing somebody else they're so
used to everything being emailed it's
kind of nice every now and then make a
call too and just say hi I'm just
calling to see how you're doing or
there's something really good going on
here and I just I let you know about it
that you know I'm 100% behind job did
something really nice for you instead of
asking them for something just um
something you're doing nice for them
people like that ever that hasn't
happened a long time in our our business
community I think you should come back
more people-to-people communication I
agree I agree I think also with the
perceived isolation that a lot of people
are going to have in response to this
virus that makes it all the more
important and I also want to take a
second just to thank you for supporting
first responders and these are really
the frontline and a safety net for us
all in many respects whether that's
military or certainly at this point
health care workers and frontline
medicine in with in response to the
coded and all the ramification to that
so I really appreciate you supporting
such a integral part such a support
system for our entire society I think
it's I think it's easy to miss these
people when you don't need them
obviously or you don't realize that you
need them and it's times like this when
it becomes so obvious how much they have
dedicated their lives to helping others
these guys these people are heroes you
know we come onto this world with
absolutely nothing every one of us came
here naked then we have nothing we come
into this world regards to what our
parents have we have nothing but I think
it's a little bit like paying rent for
being on the planet Earth and being
alive on this planet regardless of your
financial situation to do something for
somebody else asking not
in return so Lonnie's first-responders
it's their job but they caught there and
do it and after they save lives or safe
houses or people or animals they go say
hey I'm the one that's saved to thank me
they do because it's their job they
picked out that is their job to be of
service to others those are true heroes
doing it asking nothing in return but
they're doing their job or we people
they're involved in philanthropy and
anyone just helping somebody out by
carrying something for them it's still
entropic when you ever you do something
for somebody else and you ask absolutely
nothing in return it's the greatest high
you will ever get higher than whatever
we smoked in the 60s that's true I've
spoken to some of the first responders
and the Medical Systems er I see you in
New York City in Washington so on and
it's just incredible how grounded many
of them are in their sincerity with the
oath that they took in in beginning
their medical careers it's it's really
just incredibly admirable so I don't
want to necessarily take a conversation
totally in that direction but I think
it's important to at least mention I
have a note here on annual retreats and
I'd be curious to hear you expand on the
importance of annual retreat that unless
is urgently do this but yeah if you
could speak to what you do on these
retreats and yeah I try and take you see
once here and I do it twice a year we're
maybe every six months I try to do it
every six months or you take off by
yourself go someplace by yourself cook
your own food do everything by yourself
to take care of yourself and in those
days I usually do it for three days in
that time you have a piece of paper like
a tablet with you and you write down on
there least I do I write down on there
all the things in my life like that I'm
doing and the people I can't write all
the people because a lot of them okay
but you know just this once that really
stand out and then I write all the
people I'm involved with or situations
that I'm involved with that don't make
me happy I really don't want to be
involved with and then my goal the next
year is to get rid of those and this
very seldom do people ever stop and
think of what who do I want my life who
died not one in my life and why it gives
me a chance to see who I want my life
who I don't want in my life and why and
what I'd like that I'm doing and what I
don't like what I have that I don't need
and what I want to get rid it was just
kind of looking at yourself in the first
night
I'll cook dinner have a nice glass of
wine and that next day morning I'll
write pages worth by the time I leave
I'm down to maybe 10 items because I've
really convinced okay here's what's
really important here so I want to
change here's who should not be in my
life anymore him and make plans to
Amelia get him out of my life here's
what I don't want to eat anymore here's
what I don't want to do anymore here's
what business I don't want to be in
anymore you know whatever it is that you
want to change your life to be happier
you could do it in that period of time
at least give you a good start on it and
kind of reassess yourself because life
is short I don't know to be 125 years
old but life is short and even that
hundred 25 years is gonna go by very
very fast so ill try and take each year
you never know what's gonna happen my
god I have a book full of people
probably over 40 people that I've known
over the last 40 years they're no longer
with us they left their earthly bodies
they dropped them and they're elsewhere
right now so you never know when that's
gonna happen so it gives you a chance to
least every six months if you could do
it at least once here if you can't to
take a few days to yourself even there's
only two days to yourself you know and
look at your life what you like what you
don't like what you want to change what
you don't want to change and not wait
for something to happen to make you
change it
you're a lousy relationship we're all
wait till it gets really better she says
something that I'll leave her he says
something I'll leave well no that's not
gonna happen you're gonna be misery
until it does happen if it ever happens
or it doesn't happen or I hate the job
I'm in but I'm sure one day something
else will come along and you sit in that
job well why not look for something to
make a change you don't want to be you
know older your life you look back and
say God that would have changed that
when I was 10 20 30 40 50 60 years old I
was 70 years old I wish would have not
done that anymore change they're done
something different well it's an old
saying that we had in the
1960s probably before you and all your
listeners are even born or they were
little children at that time it was this
today is the first day of the rest of
your life and it is each days that first
day the rest of your life make it go
more in your direction
this is this is something I'd really
love to love to dig into a little bit
deep by annual or annual retreat and
specifically you striking someone who's
very decisive very strategic what
language or approach do you use to cut
ties with the people that you no longer
want to have in your life what is your
approach or how would you suggest people
approach that I would say in many ways
number one if it's a social contact
don't get involved anymore in any social
things that they're doing for the jitney
bite you to or you don't know if I'm
painting that you have don't call them
on the phone and just kind of you know
let them go I mean it's not like there
could be some good people that you love
but you know they're just not good for
you in your life so it's the matter of
fun I got this from this wonderful lady
this Greek friend of mine that said this
you could always love people but they're
not right for you or they're negative
people especially negative people just
gossip about everybody else love them
from afar like I love you but stay over
there stay away from me let them from
afar in other words start disconnecting
physically or telephonically from them
just stop doing it just uh just stop
here
and if they're contacting you or
reaching out to contact you do you
ignore you have a particular response to
that how would you how would you how
would you look what my normal thing
would be to be kind I don't want to be
mean to anybody if I especially they've
done nothing wrong to me but I've seen
her do wrong to other people I just
don't want them around me I would just
say to them for example one thing would
be you know thank you very much for I'm
really involved some other things right
now do you might have to get back to you
to month or two would that be okay
that's it that's it keep it simple I'm
not saying I'm going to call you the
month you might get back to you to month
or just kind of keep that distance and
little by little it goes away little by
little and goes away let out or flat out
your own personal life they're there
with you say hey you're wonderful and
I'm wonderful
but together things just aren't going
right we've got to make a change for
your sake and my sake this way nobody's
wrong the worst you could ever do is say
you're wrong you're bad for me I want
anything to do with you then the person
really feels don't validate it oh my god
they feel terrible but if you approach
it where you know it's hey I'm not the
best thing for you it's obvious because
it's turning out you're not the best
thing for me because I'm not the best
thing for you and we're both good people
I think we should go our own ways and
that's tough to do that is so tough to
do that's tough to do and I would also
be curious to ask you about any patterns
you may have seen in these retreats when
when you have looked at the column of
things that you want to do more of or
the things you want to do less of or the
people you want to spend more time with
versus less time with any patterns
emerged that you have helped you make
better decisions moving forward really
you know what consistently this pops up
in the positive column or consistently
this pops up in the negative column yes
okay let me do it yeah and let me sew a
negative in there also the hardest thing
that I found to do but it's easier now
in the last year or two of my life is to
say no I got this great don't want to
show you no thank you
can we do this no you want to go here no
but I really want to know harnessing was
to say no or I don't want to but you can
you have nothing to lose others
and the only person that's hurt by you
not doing that is you
now how did you how did you become
better at that why did it change two
years ago I did was I I did have by the
way let's call it a divine revelation
happened to me you always fired from
those three companies redken firma doll
as well as FiOS I'm from all three
companies but when I started Paul
Mitchell a couple years later I realized
something
one they fired me too I was doing a good
job but more important this is fate
had I not worked for all three companies
and learned something different from all
three I could have never started Paul
Mitchell with $700 let alone $500,000 I
could have never done it so a lot of
times things are done because it's fate
its fate that dictates you in that
direction and that's something you got
to remember there's fate many times you
can help direct fate by being able to
say no or look at an opportunity and go
for it hmm
no there's a short and powerful word
that I think almost everyone needs to
use more of you know a lot of things
that I've told you could also go to one
sentence and it's this successful or
happy people do all the things
unsuccessful or unhappy people don't
want to do
like say no or don't do this because
there's something that'd be better for
you if you did it yeah well on that on
that theme in the last handful of years
doesn't have to be anything specific are
there any new beliefs or behaviors
habits that it most positively affected
your life I think the one that I'm sure
I think the one that most policy
affected my life is last few years is
the ability to say no I'm not interested
no don't even present it to me with all
due respect because I'm over I'm
overloaded with things to do but in a
kind way I don't know I don't do it
sharp and cut anybody off I do them in a
very nice way is the ability to say no I
don't want this I don't want to do this
no I don't want to hear this to be able
to say no but saving it nicely that was
one of the biggest things next thing is
to learn how to just be and then have
learn the last few years how to just be
you could enter a room and just have
your presence in that room without
having to talk to everybody if you don't
want to in other words how to just be or
by yourself just be just be like you and
the room or you in the middle of a crowd
just be not having to talk to someone
because you feel well I gotta talk to
you so I can't just stand here talk to
because you want to be able to be on
your own and like yourself and just be I
was one now I go in a room I'll talk to
everything in that room and I thought to
everybody but sometimes it's good to you
can still do that but just know the
power of just being just be you as the
entity that's within your body so listen
to this way regardless what your beliefs
are we all know there's some kind of a
life form in us because when we go and
we die all that's left is this is call
it meat that's starting to rot okay
there's there was something in us
whatever your beliefs are what happens
when you died that's that's up to the
individual but so there's something in
you what there's something in you why
can't you just be and all of a sudden
look through your eyes and feel that
maybe that entity isn't inside my brain
maybe an entity is surrounding my body
by about a foot or two around me when
you do that all of a sudden your space
starts expanding say oh wow
I feel like my space is expanding I was
through my eyes in my brain I thought
but now I'm kind of looking at the world
a little different way just learn how to
be and as at life for menu even though
you're looking through the eyes could be
expanding around you it's a different
outlook that you have on things a big
different at work do you ever practice
that being or that expanded
consciousness outside of your body at
home is that something that you have as
a regular practice not as as time goes
on it just it just is just with you
whether you're inside or outside it's
just with you if there is light were to
stop right now and say okay where am I
well me the entity is surrounding my
body by a few feet I'm still synced
through the eyes but I could feel the
energy around me are you going to room
and do the same thing I have been a
crowd a bunch of people and it's the
same thing it's just been developed over
time and there's many many different
practices that will get you there many
different practices and it's not rites
and rituals that you pick up out of uh
no disrespect any good books are written
there are a lot of ruling and once there
it's uh it's the acknowledgement of
realizing it yourself that you actually
realize that scene and sealant it's like
whatever the mind can conceive and
believe the final achieve it's pretty
strong now you you have a treasure trove
of quotes on Maxim's uh is there a
particular quote it could be the one you
just said but is there any particular
quote or maxim that you live your life
buyer think of so yes there is it is
probably one of the oldest one around
people talk about it but very few over
practice act and it's one quick little
sentence do unto others as you would
have others do unto you
it's an oldie but a goodie but it's sure
Israel yeah diggity
are there any any books that you have
gifted frequently to other people or any
BM reread yes there is the one I've
given away the most and I suggest to
people is 70 or 80 years old the name of
the book is how to win friends and
influence people by Dale Carnegie this
book is when the best books ever written
on how to acknowledge and make people
feel good when you talk to them
as basically there's how do I be
respectful like doing to others as you'd
have understood to you but it's when the
best books and I recommend it to so many
people how to win friends and influence
people by Dale Carnegie maybe it's $19
and paperback maybe it's less than that
but it is a great bucket people should
read it twice because it's that good
and it did really teach you how to talk
to your fellow man and and you'll be be
confronted by your fellow man they
confront you don't communicate with
people and make them feel good
that is an excellent book I just want to
want a second that recommendation
I read that many many years ago and have
read it multiple times it's an older
book so of course they're aspects of it
that has have aged but the principles
really stand the test of time that's
that's a fantastic plastic book are
there any others that come to mind
uh well I would say for people to
understand that you could be fired from
jobs and the book hasn't been written
yet just the documentary was made and
still make it in life because you help
other people out and that was what I
mentioned earlier in your show get the
clock you mentary a good fortune I think
it's four dollars to rent it if you
wanted to on Amazon or YouTube or one of
those it lets people know but the
important thing is how to not only
succeed and grow but do it by helping
others along the way and asking nothing
in return and I'm sorry to write a book
on that write down there's taking a long
time to write this book but I'll
eventually get it done you you've spoken
about and we've spoken about the time
that you were fired are there any
particular failures of yours that you
think we're extremely important in terms
of teaching you lessons or somehow
setting you up for later success are
there any that come to mind definitely
I'd say quite a few of them for example
Oh many years ago when telephone
reselling was popular I got into that
business or I invested money in it we
invest money in a company and then they
buy so many telephone minutes real cheap
and they turn around and sell it to
somebody else for a little bit more well
you know I'd lost a lot of money in that
day and didn't go well but I learned a
little bit about that business but the
business failed but some of the
knowledge stayed with me and then later
on I got involved in another business
about ten years ago that was going to
revolutionize cellular phones how we
communicate with the world well to date
up as I stuck with it today that
business is rocket are okay IT rocket
phones and Wi-Fi systems rocket are okay
IT we now have a telephone that's out
we've just started selling here in the
last year that it's a regular smartphone
but it has on it 3d without glasses yes
3d movies without glasses on a cell
phone on a smartphone it also has what
the world needs right now and that is
telemedicine seven days a week 24 hours
a day a Dodgers on the phone with you
looking at you you're lucky
tempeh knows that you it also has Wi-Fi
for the world where someone could buy
the cheapest SIM card they could have
like just for talking text or maybe $25
whatever for just talking text see how
the number but you put it in this phone
and with the worldwide Wi-Fi we have you
call anywhere in the world and it
doesn't cost you anything
and has a lot of other things on it but
if you go online to rock our okay ITU
did someone can look it up rocket phones
and what it does it but the
revolutionary thing was I learned how
you have a lot of expensive things but
sometimes having the very best and being
too expensive doesn't work either and I
learned that with telephones from
failing I tried before to come out with
telephones years ago it went nowhere
never even got off the ground so I
learned if you have the very very best
and you can put in everyone's hands
realistically Wow well the top phone
that rocket sells this is a tough smart
phone this is a first-class smart phone
all the way is 299 dollars that's the
most expensive let me have and then I
learned also by working with people like
NASA in the space agency and others that
there's a lot of good agencies out there
that are government type agencies or
related type agencies that want to work
with you NASA just became our partner we
now go to develop phones and hopefully
we'll have the first ones out in a
couple of months that when you touch the
phone the back of the phone neutralizes
all the bad stuff of your hands see when
you're in outer space there's a lot of
bad stuff up there you can't have that
cheerio floating around or viruses or
anything so they have a coating that
goes on the back of a phone but it's
going back on the back of our phones or
partner that when you touch it all of a
sudden all that junk and all those
diseases on your hands are neutralized
by just picking up your cell phone so
what I learned through failures trying
to be in the technical industry than you
nothing about was get for some people
that are very honest again with people
that are really on top of on top of
their game make them your partners one
way or another and all of a sudden offer
a better product a better quality of
better things others don't have and
don't have to charge them to $1500 that
our research said we should charge for
these phones now of course we have
phones as you know less than that quite
less than $99 50 bucks and so forth but
I learned that through failure today
we're doing really good we're rolling
out through stores right now over the
Internet and it's doing quite well not
just in our country but several other
countries too now if we take we can take
rocket as an example yeah you mentioned
you're not you're not on email because
you would be inundated so how do you how
do you choose the for-profit and
philanthropic projects that you dedicate
your energies to because you have I
would imagine an embarrassment of riches
in the sense that you have more
opportunities to choose from you could
possibly ever take advantage of that is
correct no how do you choose the first
thing is whatever I'm gonna get involved
in it's muli as an investor in these
days whatever I get involved in a little
bit of advice and a lot of PR whatever I
get involved in is it gonna do the
greatest good for the greatest number
and does it excite me to think this
could happen even in your technological
fields I'm not a technocratic so I'm not
technologically well educated but I know
enough to know what the end result of
that technical advancement is and I say
oh this would be great for everybody
well I'm excited about it are you
kidding this is super I know the first
time I was overseas and I made phone
calls to the United States and one of
her phones and it cost me absolutely
nothing through rock why fight and I'm
used to having when I'm overseas and
very expensive sell your phone bills
about this is great I can't wait till
everybody hears about this thing I can't
wait my god think of all the money
they're gonna save if they save that
money to buy some nice for their family
or invest at some place you know those
little those tens to $20 and $100 a
month adds up so I got excited what
excites me it's what excites me and
right now I'm over in a date I get more
things thrown at me for a lot of them
are for no money JP just get involved
with us and you help direct us a little
bit my answer is guys don't have the
time Phil entropically I'm more involved
in anything else and what business is
I'm involved in now my investments are
really what they are you know I'm kind
of tapped out right now I'm over
inundated because I
I spent less than 20 percent of my time
on business the rest is doing something
good to change the world can you
describe what that looks like for you
that that eighty percent that is non
business how do you how do you hadn't
currently spend your time that way oh my
goodness oh well I told you about the
peace love and happiness right we talked
about the sea shepherd big support of
the sea shepherd they had a movie on
about the Matty B series called well
wars with Paul Watson and what we do is
we do on the open seas and we stop those
that are approaching you legally like
the Japanese that we're killing eleague
Wells illegally on the open seas they
you expose it all through that well
worse thing anyways we were chasing them
down and they're also poachers are
poaching Turtles things like that and oh
my god it's terrible are killing sharks
needlessly there's it's crazy stuff so
my involvement is I talk with Paul I
talk with sea shepherds I hold events
for them I go to events for them and
when a lot of poachers were out running
our ships I bought them a Coast Guard
Cutter
and we refitted the whole thing painted
camouflaged blue so we go right after
those poachers and stop the destruction
of these species going on a planet right
now on uh grow Appalachia I went around
the country trying to find out how I
could help out our nation in 2009 10 11
when unemployment was very high and a
lot of people are on food stamps and I
decided the food industry so I went out
and I partnered up I look for a good
partner I found Brea college out of an
area of Kentucky and they partnered with
me on this and I financed the entire
thing where we went out and my goal is
let's take there's a hundred and fifty
thousand people in the Appalachian
Mountains that's about six or seven
states that are on food stamps I'm gonna
get at least half of them off food
stamps so we started crumple Asia where
we had teams that we paid for and others
that were volunteers we would go out and
teach people in the Appalachian
Mountains how to garden I would pay for
their irrigation their supplies their
tools that are seeds and they're know
how to teach them how to grow their own
gardens number one was you grow enough
food for you and your family and here's
how you
can so there's a lot of food for the
winter by putting it in these jars sure
say you can food right so that your
first year you're self-sufficient your
second year you grow more it this was
the goal and a lot of them did it you
grow more than you would normally grow
and now you sell the excess to farmers
markets or local grocery stores has
organically grown local produce and make
yourself some money eventually want to
eat the food stamps anymore but when you
send the food stamps back please have a
letter do not put this back into the
pile for food stamps take this off the
federal deficit the deficit is too high
because well I had nothing I got food
stamps now it's time for me to pay back
and lower that u.s. deficit and I ask
them to do that and hopefully they did
well a lot of them went now all of a
sudden saying let's expand it so we
bought them a dozen chickens now they
have all the A's they could possibly
want some have honey we have these there
now and it expanded expanded expanded so
I wish spend time going back and forth
from there talking to people doing
interviews about it for the homeless we
have the most incredible things here in
Austin Texas
we started it's called the community
mobile loaves & Fishes the community we
built an Allen Graham was the genius
behind this I just pitched in the money
and some of my time we built two hundred
and forty little houses for homeless
people chronic homeless people people
that have been without any kind of a
shelter for at least a year those are
those living under bridges leaving in
tents but no place to go into maybe the
first ones another priority to go into
the buffalos and fishes but community
here in Austin and to go there you got
to pay rent you got to pay some rent not
a lot but a little bit of rent so you
feel like you're part of it if you give
somebody a handout they feel like oh
this is charity they don't feel good if
you give them a hand up they feel good
so you charge a little bit of rent there
and we also have gardens wood shop metal
shop craft shop and so forth and a lot
of them now have an income because they
can make crafts a gun to garden they can
work they can sell all the extra stuff
and I just fell recently rebuilding
right now actually an entrepreneur
Center a big one so that if they have an
idea they go
that one Center and there's little
things in that center or set up to help
them make their entrepreneurial spirits
come true and then I'm building for them
also we're helping to build an aqua
centers they could grow their own fish
there so now they have vegetables they
have fish they have a way to start
making an income and these are ways that
make people that before we're on the
burden of the community now a lot of
them are getting jobs and they're paying
taxes and they still have a beautiful
place to live in a beautiful community I
did the same in Los Angeles because
that's where I was homeless and I'm it
was a big contributor for many years and
up until this last year I haven't gotten
around to this last year but I'd go down
at least once a year and lecture to them
on homelessness say I was homeless
here's how I got out of it guys you know
and if I could do it you could do it and
that should that's just a couple of
examples of some of the things that we
do they're enormous with Bobby Kennedy
Waterkeeper Alliance my god saving the
waterways of the world we started with
the United States where we would go in
raise money and we would bust the
polluters even the big guys Lee would
bust him in court one of the biggest
cases took us 16 years but we won and
what do we do we leave all the money
locally so the local could be leave it
all locally we raise our own money so
the local water keeper group can be able
to have boats or hire people to make
sure that they patrol the area and that
it's never redone again worked out
really well you mentioned quite a few
things including a community I'm here in
Austin as well and I have not yet been I
have friends who have been to the
community and have said it's just
a clever that it's it's it's it's really
it boggles the mind as to how well many
of the elements are working let me tell
you about a new one I got to you about
of doing okay guys I want to forget say
this one this I just got involved with a
couple of months ago and there was an
article in our review journal here in
Austin about it is a little group
started and I gave them you know six
figures to make it a little bigger group
you know they have a little more there
because they need it that badly here's
what they do and I'm hundred percent
behind these guys they have a hundred
and 70 some-odd volunteers only one
person was on payroll now they have a
second person because I was able to
handle that for them too
but here's what they do they go around
to dev about 50 and I want to expand it
now to 300 they go to 50 different
restaurants grocery stores key drink
services and they get all the leftover
food for example if you make a fresh
sandwich to sell and it doesn't sell in
eight hours
well they get rid of it well this is all
picked up by the volunteers and they
take it directly to whether it's mobile
loaves & Fishes or food banks for those
learners are hungry they take it
directly to the source so all this food
that is wasted the United States
probably waste thirty 40 percent of its
food goes directly to the people that
need it and someone's already picking it
up so they don't have to destroy it and
delivery to the other people this is
there be an answer by the way to the
United States and other parts of the
world on people that need food all the
food that's thrown away the companies
the restaurants the caterers the the
people that have the sandwich shops or
whatever still have the same customers
but instead of throwing it away the good
food is going to people that really need
it that aren't their customers anyways
everyone benefits and that's really
exciting this I think is gonna be a
beautiful beautiful example of how the
rest of the communities throughout the
whole United States and other parts rule
could do it it's very exciting in
deciding and I will include links to
everything you mentioned in these show
notes to people which still be able to
find it tuned up long for fresh podcast
and I just said a few
while questions have been very generous
your time and I'd want to chew up your
entire afternoon but just just a few
final questions and I'll start with one
that that I always like to ask because
you are clearly very high-energy he has
been massively productive he's been
focus to an extraordinary degree in many
chapters in your life could you speak to
a and you did mention some hard times
but could you speak to what you do in
moments of doubt if you have them or
when you've gone through emotionally
difficult times what are the the the
tools in the toolkit that have helped
you to get through those times or out of
those those lower periods the old way
was I will get a piece of paper in on
half of it right all the challenges and
things not so good about that on the
other half of the loan right what I
could have learned from it and not may
happen again and then I always remember
that whatever happens this is the
hardest part of it all whatever happens
no matter how bad it seems one or two
years from now you're to look back and
say oh god I wish I didn't get that
upset about it so I'm gonna give you a
one-liner that I remembered and
hopefully you're listing on us remember
also because it proves to be true in 99%
of all cases
here's the one-liner in the end
everything will be okay and if it's not
okay it's not the end think about all
the things that were hassling your wife
think of all the things are else in your
life and you look back at it a year to
later we got like on through it it was
okay I got through it but the time you
don't think that but if you just put
your head no matter what happened the
past all the bad things even happened to
you or any person out there in the end
everything will be okay
and if it's not okay it's not the end
yeah because many times when things are
really buried others so yeah oh my god
it is never gonna end good things
there's a good thing to remember is that
is that the type of reminder and mantra
that you used early on in your career or
for instance when you were homeless the
first or second time when Ella lesson
nope that was only recent my first or
second time homeless it was okay I gotta
eat where do I get money to get food are
you kidding I want to eat you know where
do I get money I got the shelter of a
car where they give any other way my
thought was first of all was the next
party food I eat gonna eat right now
you've got food I got clothing already
shelter I didn't need care with so
Kayla's the first thing next thing was
okay I don't get a job you know what do
I do here how do I create something
there like one step at a time it's it's
kind of like it's a cinch by the inch
and it's hard by the yard
[Laughter]
what do you think what big one what is
it time you got a win soon as you get a
win it gives you that energy to go on to
the next one one step at a time
now you're you have a really just
incredibly the prod spectrum of lions so
I'm gonna I'm gonna be greedy I want to
ask this question feel free to say I've
given you enough or you can give me
another but if you had a gigantic
billboard metaphorically speaking I mean
let's just call it a billboard to put a
quote a question and image and words on
which would be transmitted to billions
of people what would you consider
putting what might you consider putting
on that billboard in big letters do unto
others dot dot dot as you would have
others do unto you and in the end
everything will be okay and if it's not
okay it's not the end that's what I
would put out there I love it
well I jump always has been so much fun
I it's pleasure sir you're a real
pleasure to spend time with hopefully
we'll have a chance and once we get
through the storm of coronavirus to
spend some time in person
and I thank you on behalf of my
listeners for all the incredible stories
and lessons learned and I hope we get a
chance to do it again yeah buddy thank
you so much and I love peace and
happiness to all your listeners hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell out and just drop in if your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn marketing solutions right now
the world is changing a lot is changing
and businesses are adapting in different
ways so in these uncertain times how do
you ensure your marketing goals are met
how do you ensure your mark against the
results that you need and want with more
than 62 million decision-makers on
LinkedIn you're able to connect with the
right business leaders as well as people
who are looking to find products
services and education to help their
companies it's no surprise that 78% of
b2b marketers rate LinkedIn is the most
effective social media platform and
helping their organization achieve
specific objectives LinkedIn marketing
can help you build campaigns use an
objective based advertising allowing you
to customize the campaign experience
based on the action you
your customer take in other words that's
true whether you're trying to drive
clicks to website generate leads or even
generate video views my team that is Tim
Ferriss show team is using the platform
right now on LinkedIn to invite people
to sign up for my five bullet Friday
newsletter LinkedIn has the targeting
tools that can help you focus on
reaching your precise audience down to
their job title company name location
and more in fact you can reach people
you already know based on who has
visited your site or who you've
contacted in the past if LinkedIn ads
can help all types of businesses get the
marketing results that they need today
see how LinkedIn can help you with a
free $100 LinkedIn ad credit to launch
your first campaign just visit
linkedin.com slash TFS that's
linkedin.com slash TFS terms and
conditions of life this episode is
brought to you by Eero uer oh I love
zero and I don't know about you guys but
since kovat hit Wi-Fi is also taken a
hit because everyone's home and spending
much more time home at least and my
girlfriend and I were using the Wi-Fi
constantly we noticed dead spots
throughout the house things would drop
off calls recordings you name it it was
a huge pain in the ass and ultimately I
grabbed euro which is originally
recommended to me by Kevin rose and it
is the Wi-Fi your home deserves it
blankets it with fast reliable Wi-Fi not
just inside but outside too so you're
creating a mesh network and they can
extend that your coverage so you can
enjoy the nice weather out on your deck
get work done wherever so this has been
a absolute game changer for me it's
super super easy to set up sets up in
minutes I despite having been involved
with tech for so long I'm not really
fantastic it's setting things up and
this was dead simple you just plug it
right into your modem or a motive router
box and you manage it from a super
simple app with some very cool features
like pausing the Wi-Fi for dinner
receiving alerts of any device attempts
to join your network it's really really
easy gyro eliminates poor coverage dead
spots and buffering you'll have
consistently strong signal wherever you
need it so for instance my girlfriend's
upstairs um downstairs and we had very
erratic coverage prior to using it now
it's very very consistent
apple homekit users euros got you
covered with enhanced privacy and safety
controls that give connected devices
only the permissions they need to do
what you want
in your home and on the internet so euro
has fixed my issues with Wi-Fi at home
you can get your Wi-Fi issues fixed as
soon as tomorrow go to erode comm slash
Tim and enter code
Tim T I am at checkout to get free next
day shipping with your order that's eer
o comm slashed him code Tim at checkout
to get your ear a delivered with free
next day shipping you must use this URL
to receive this offer one more time
check it out
euro dot-com / Tim code
[Applause]